the jurgen experience like that kind of
thinking
is what happens in hollywood and it's
not because they really think that way
it's because they're terrified that they
step outside the lines and they'll be
you know oh he's another scott baio or
something you know even chris pratt gets
in trouble because he's christian i saw
that he was the worst chris for a while
though he is the nicest [ __ ] guy i've
ever met in my life
i mean i've met people equally nice what
were people i don't honestly i just saw
something where it was just like where's
chris or something i don't give a [ __ ]
what they with their thing is they're
all insane people that hate their jobs
that are sitting in front of the cubicle
when their boss isn't looking they're
tweeting bad things about chris pratt
it's definitely interesting that like
how the like power of like people though
that can kind of like blow up something
that sort of like you know
just maybe not that big of a deal and it
becomes a big deal because that's a nice
way to put it what it is is a bully
pylon that's what it is you see someone
being vulnerable and you could snipe at
them and you don't have any
repercussions and they're not in front
of you so you attack the guy he's not
done he hasn't done nothing i don't know
honestly
what's the thing is like that people are
even like i don't know anything about it
but chris pat is like one of the nicest
people i've ever met in my life he's
genuinely friend i've i've been in
hunting camp with him he's nice to
everybody to the the ladies that work in
the kitchen where were you guys hunting
elk
where in utah
that's crazy so you just like went to
like a like camp for like a couple like
we're there for you yeah for a week yeah
that's interesting yeah did you get uh
elk yes i did yeah that's interesting
and he did too um but
my point is like i've seen him interact
with people like sure sits at the these
cafeteria style tables with everybody
with you know people from all walks of
life he's like super normal yeah yeah
yeah and i've seen i've been around him
multiple times like that he's a super
kind super normal guy it'll be
interesting it's fun too he's a fun guy
to be around i'm excited to see that
mario movie did you see that no the
mario he's like the i'm pretty sure he's
the voice of mario oh the voice like
i thought you were saying like he's
gonna be a lot live action mario no no
i'm pretty sure i'm pretty sure it's all
animated but
um
he's you know
what else has he done other than the
guardians of the galaxy he's got
something else oh he's a transit park
thing yeah yeah no he's in i was he's in
the new uh jack car series that they're
doing for uh amazon
do you know what that is jack carr is uh
he's got these uh
amazing books about this this character
james reese this navy seal james reese a
really great like thriller like a tom
clancy
yeah very similar jack reacher type
thing okay yeah but this guy james reese
is his
primary character and he's being played
for like amazon or like something like
that
anyway point is he's one of the rare
guys that's like
he's he's kind of outside the lines in
terms of his ideology he's a christian
and he's pretty open about it and and
because of that they attack him it's
something so simple like he just
believes in jesus and he likes you know
he likes to be
a good person sure you're like [ __ ] him
it's definitely it's it's an interesting
time